ADD UNDERMINING DONALD TRUMP.
MR. CHAIRMAN, THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US, WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION, MICHELLE MALKIN.
MICHELLE MALKIN, FOX NEWS
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGIST
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT SEBASTIAN GORKA.
MICHELLE, YOUR REACTION TO ALL
OF THIS, AND THIS IS REALLY JUST
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
>> IT IS.
THE STENCH EMANATING FROM THE
TOP ECHELONS OF THE FBI ARE
BEYOND FETID.
THIS IS THE MALODOROUS MARK OF
THE DEEP STATES WANT AND AS
DESPERATE AS THE DESPERATION
MEDIA IS, THERE IS NOTHING THEY
CAN DO TO COVER IT UP.
THEY WILL KEEP REPEATING THE
SAME TIRED FALSE TALKING POINTS
ABOUT THIS BEING SOME SORT OF
PARTISAN WITCH HUNT ON THE PART
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
THAT PURE PSYCHOLOGICAL
PROJECTION AND YOU CAN'T HIDE
THE FACT THAT IT WAS CAREER FBI
PEOPLE AND AN OBAMA APPOINTEE
AND MICHAEL HOROWITZ.
IT GOT THE IG WITHIN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY THAT
SIGNED OFF ON THIS FIRING LAST
FRIDAY.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO, AS YOU
SAID, SEAN, WITH DONALD TRUMP.
AND YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
YOU'VE BEEN SAYING IT FOR A LONG
TIME, THAT THIS WAS THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT AS A MATTER
OF HISTORICAL CONTEXT THIS DID
NOT JUST COME OUT OF NOWHERE.
I REPORTED OVER THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS ABOUT HOW THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND PARTICULARLY
PEOPLE IN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
THWARTED AT EVERY TURN
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
INVESTIGATIONS.
IT HAPPENED IN JUSTICE, THE EPA,
INTERIOR, EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THESE CIVILIAN AGENCIES.
SO YOU ADD THE NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS AND DANGERS OF THE
HIJACKING OF OUR INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES.
AND A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
>> Sean: IS TO UNDERMINED A
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT AND TO
ASSIST A FELON LAWBREAKER AND
LITERALLY EXONERATE SOMEBODY WHO
COMMITTED MANY LAWS.
THAT IS A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
LET ME GO TO SEBASTIAN GORKA.
RICE, KLAPPER, BRENNAN.
COMEY, PAGE, STRZOK.
LORETTA LYNCH.
YOU HAVE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, TOP DOWN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: DEEP STATE.
>> LET'S REMEMBER, THIS
INDIVIDUAL, ANDREW McCABE,
HE'S JUST A SMALL PART OF A
MASSIVE CONSPIRACY AND AGAIN,
THE OPI, IT SOUNDS VERY ANODYNE,
THE OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY, THAT THE IAD OF
THE FBI.
THAT'S THE INTERNAL AFFAIRS
DIVISION AND THEY SAID THIS GUY
CANNOT GET HIS PENSION.
THAT IS A MASSIVE BLOW AND IT'S
JUST THE BEGINNING, BUT NOW
COMES THE REAL TEST.
NOW HA SESSIONS HAS TO CLEAN.